Well, how what's up? I'm streaming, by the way. >> This
is Did Did you see what happened? >> Yeah, I think so.
>> Yeah. Like, dude, Charlie's going to be [__]
dead. >> Yeah, I'm pretty sure he's already dead. >> dude.
We're [__] We are We are We are so [__]
>> By we, you mean we as a country right now, the United
States, and the current >> like like Yeah, like that the
party, but like mostly like I think that the I think that we're
super [__] I agree. Hold on. Wait, I'll I'll text
you on
I I don't want to do anything crazy that's going to ruin our
[__] On both Z's website and Reddit account, her
organization's stated goals were taking the fight directly to
Charlie Kirk by following him around on college campuses. It
is.